I'm gonna do something that every kid around the world would love to do.
I'm gonna walk around London and check out all the sites...
...where Harry Potter was filmed.
First stop on the Harry Potter tour is Diagon Alley.
Well actually, it's not really called Diagon Alley.
It's just the inspiration for the film.
It's an alley full of old bookshops...
...and a lot of the bookshops are full of books of magic and potions.
This was the visitors' entrance to the Ministry of Magic in the Order of the Phoenix...
...and that was the entrance to the Leaky Cauldron.
This is Leadenhall Market and it was in the first film...
...and it actually looks like a movie set, but it's a real place.
This is the famous railway station where Harry Potter...
...and all of his buds would get on the train and go to school in Scotland.
This is so cool, I didn't know this existed in real life.
Platform 9 3/4.
This is quite a spot for a photo there, huh?